alors je demande à céret la lune à une
petite augmentation
on est parti de très bas donc plus alors
mon cher civile
ce que je souhaiterais pour nous l'année
prochaine c'est qu'est la limite je
présente pas le nez dit que j'aimerais
présenter une émission on en a parlé
ensemble déjà avec valérie bénaïm ou
alors kelly je vais présenter une
mission d'étude marange le coup avec amy
ah ouais vraiment je sais à quel point
tu tues gère correctement la société
mais je trouve qu'on pourrait avoir une
petite idée moi perso de noël parce que
chaque année et puis trop de la
réalisation des salaires et abonnements
à votre bon coeur
voilà c'est tout ce que je demande
d'être encore là et de vivre encore de
grandes laventure avec tout le monde à
tous et bien sûr si lille je reste
non mais non merci ma compagnie dans
toutes nos séries m'ont complètement
mérité succès rigolade
je pense que 2018 va être ta plus belle
année 2010 parce que je demanderai à
cyril pour 2018 se serait d'être un peu
plus